so there's something interesting going
on and I sort of unsure actually as to
the direction things are going and I
want to see what you think and I'm
talking about the Democratic primary the
Democratic primary sort of has
evaporated
during the virus without actually being
finished although we were pretty close
to wrapping it up so here's how I kind
of see what what's taken place so far we
had the beginning of the Democratic
primary we had debates hard-fought many
candidates candidates started dropping
off we had our first votes in Iowa in
New Hampshire this feels like years ago
because so much has happened since and
then we had South Carolina South
Carolina Joe Biden wins a bit by a
bigger than expected margin the momentum
clearly shifts mayor pete drops out and
endorses Biden Amy Klobuchar drops out
and endorses Biden Kamala Harris
endorses Biden Biden gets more wins on
Super Tuesday and it starts to seem as
though the window is closing for Bernie
Sanders Bloomberg endorses Biden keeps
winning he wouldn't Super Tuesday he
went Super Tuesday to he win Super
Tuesday three
we now have Joe Biden ahead 12:15 to
nine oh nine a lead of 306 delegates
Tulsi drops out and endorses Biden much
to the dismay of both her supporters and
Bernie supporters we were supposed to
have a primary today in Georgia but it's
been postponed due to the virus Puerto
Rico was supposed to vote in five days
that's postponed due to the virus and
now the primary is barely being
discussed now I understand why of course
people are staying home in some states
at least people are trying to deal with
the corona virus pandemic but what is
the path forward because on the one hand
the entire pandemic has actually
reenergized Bernie supporters who were
saying coronavirus makes the case for
Medicare for also much more clear
Biden's m.i.a Bernie's doing livestreams
a sort of resurgence in some corners of
the internet anyway for Bernie Sanders
and indeed Joe Biden has been missing he
resurfaced yesterday did a short stream
about the pandemic it didn't go well I
guess it was he had a podium at home and
it sort of looked like his living room
although it might have been a green
screen with a picture of his living room
I couldn't really tell everything going
wrong including the teleprompter failing
for Joe Biden take a look at this short
clip beefed up the number of responders
dealing with the crushed knees crushing
cases and an in addition to that in
addition to that we have to make sure
that we we are in a position that we are
well let me let me go the second thing
I'm spoken of in it the president must
use the defense production act so it
wasn't good and then looking at polling
we're also getting less and less polling
data because polling has also slowed
down due to the pandemic looking at just
recent polls over the last six days we
have national polls from last Wednesday
where Biden was plus 24 and plus 21 poll
out of Georgia where Biden was plus 44
Thursday in Connecticut saying Biden is
plus 17 and then from Friday we had a
hypothetical matchup poll where both
Biden and Bernie are ahead of Trump by 6
and then a national poll which has Biden
plus 12 according to that poll the lead
shrinking for Biden heading into the
weekend but again no polling data at all
from this week yet Biden's lead on
Bernie seemingly shrinking a little bit
so what happens now I mean it is it over
in the sense that the the remaining
primaries if they happen will simply be
a formality does coronavirus change the
perspectives on Bernie and Biden so
drastically is it one of those Black
Swan events that creates a new window of
opportunity for Bernie Sanders where
there before did not exist one is this
why Bernie Sanders hasn't dropped out
and then bigger picture is anyone even
thinking about the primary and most
importantly I'm seeing some people start
to say there's not going to be an
election in November so we don't even
really have to pay attention that's very
dangerous thinking it is incredibly
unlikely that the election in November
is actually postponed we already talked
about the legal issues around that and
around the fact that there is a deadline
in December
for electors to place their votes on the
basis of how their respective states
voted ideally things will have improved
dramatically by November although under
Donald Trump maybe not we're now hearing
he's thinking of letting it rip so to
speak but the odds of postponing a
presidential election are very very low
and anybody counting on that is unlikely
to be right so let me know how you see
things what do you think is going on
with the Democratic primary has anything
actually shifted due to coronavirus or
is it just like we we saw before
loud enclaves on Twitter and reddit and
the internet and where it particularly
if you haven't voted yet if your state
hasn't yet voted I would love to hear
what your perspective is on what's going
on as well
I've got something really cool today the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to david pakman.com slash skill will
get a premium membership to Skillshare
for two months for free skill shares the
online learning community offering
thousands of classes on almost anything
you can imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video